are ordinary people able to do terrible
things and if so how many would give a
strong electric shock to an innocent
other just because they are following an
order to answer these questions we can
look at the controversial work of a man
who just wanted to find answers to his
family's horrific past
in 1961 stanley milgram a young
psychologist wanted to find out how
ordinary citizens were able to commit
acts of unspeakable evil in nazi germany
his theory some people do horrific
things because they obey even the most
wicked leaders to test his theory
milgram designed a clever experiment
that changed our understanding of human
behavior forever
the milgram experiment involved three
people an authority called the
experimenter who was dressed in a lab
coat to appear powerful a volunteer who
was assigned to be the teacher
and a victim the so-called student
the teacher was the test subject whereas
the experimenter and student were both
actors
following orders the teacher would test
a student who was sitting in another
room by asking them questions for every
wrong answer the experimenter would ask
the teacher to inflict an electric shock
up to a life-threatening 450 volts
[Music]
before he began
milgram asked his colleagues what they
expected the outcome to be almost all of
them agreed that only a few of the
volunteers would obey and inflict
electric shocks on innocent others what
do you think would anyone administer
shocks higher than 300 volts
milgram then advertised his experiment
as a study on memory and learning at the
campus of yale university people signed
up without any idea of what they were
really getting themselves into
the experiment began with the volunteers
meeting the other participants the
volunteers then pulled a card to draw
their role little did they know that
they could only draw the teacher next
they would be given a sample of a light
electric shock in order to experience
firsthand what the others would have to
go through
to start the experimenter and the
teacher were seated in one room and the
student was strapped to a chair in an
adjacent room the teacher and student
were able to communicate but not see
each other
the experimenter then gave the teacher a
list of questions the teacher would then
read out the questions and the student
would press a button to indicate a
response for every false answer the
teacher would administer a shock
starting at 15 volts and increasing in
15 volt increments up to 450.
what the teacher didn't know was that
the student didn't actually receive any
shocks instead a tape recorder was used
to play various responses
in the beginning the teacher would hear
a protest or bangs against the wall
if shocks would increase the reactions
would become louder and in case someone
would go all the way the learner would
fall silent
in case the teacher became hesitant and
asked to stop the experimenter would
resort to the following four prompts
first he would say please continue if
that was unsuccessful he would go on
with the experiment requires that you
continue then it is absolutely essential
that you continue and lastly you have no
other choice you must go on
along the way the volunteers displayed
signs of extreme tension such as
sweating trembling and even
uncontrollable laughing fits the
experiment would be stopped only after
all four prompts had been used or the
maximum voltage of 450 volts had been
given three times
milgram found that of all participants
100 percent gave at least 300 volts and
65 went all the way to 450 volts the
experiment was later criticized for
being unethical because it deceived
innocent people into performing what
seemed to be terrible acts of violence
however his experiment was successfully
replicated many times involving
different populations and leading to
similar findings
milgram himself left us with this to
think about it may be that we are
puppets puppets controlled by the
strings of society but at least we are
puppets with perception with awareness
and perhaps our awareness is the first
step to our liberation
what do you think would you follow or
question the orders if you were one of
milgram's participants and what can we
as a society teach future generations to
help prevent horrific acts that can
happen when ordinary people blindly
follow an authority let us know your
thoughts in the comments below
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts